dai ragazzi lo sapete come inizio basta
sempre uguale sempre uguale basta i
ragazzi per questo video sono tra i j
e volevo fare un video diverso appunto
il dato il fatto che in questo periodo
sto registrando dalla mia camera
molti di voi continuano a chiedermi
nonostante il tempo sia passato e quindi
risposto è stato quando miliardo di
volte
quali sono i videogiochi insomma della
mia mano ho sempre detto ragazzi che ho
giocato tanto metal gear bugs bunny los
in time questi sono stati i videogiochi
di quand'ero piccolo si vede perché ciò
si vede un sacco di roba bunnies come
sono a casa mia adesso quindi a torino
quindi nella mia magica stanza nonché
mausoleo del canale fa vigenti v
possiedo appunto questi giochi
proprio qui e quindi ho detto ma perché
lo facciamo un video dove facciamo un
mix di gameplay del parigi che aveva 6
anni
proviamo a fare questo video dove
riprendo ovviamente non sarà un gameplay
quindi con webcam e gameplay perché sto
riprendendo il nintendo pre a vedere se
riesco a far rivedere un po che cosa c'è
in giro detto ciao ragazzi questa è la
mia cameretta molto bella come potete
vedere sempre il solito la solita roba
allora c'è da dire una cosa è cambiata
molto nel corso del tempo perché adesso
è diventata una sorta di magazzino di
oggetti che mi regalano quindi non è non
è più come una volta una volta era
proprio cosparsa di giochi e balze le so
alcuni sono in garage
alcuni sono andata mi a milano quindi
una sorta di magazzino di roba comunque
degli oggetti abbastanza significativi
sono rimasti comincia
allora il primo gioco che non giocherò
perché dovrei installarlo ed è veramente
un casino questo questo non è stato il
mio primo gioco è stato il primo che ho
visto quando iniziato il video perché
sta sullo scaffale di in alto il the
sims pensa l'abbiamo mandato non c'è
anche bisogno perché lo conosciamo tutti
the city quindi portelli e l'unico gioco
tra tutti che non proverò e qua e qua vi
voglio another cod
questo gioco qua è stato uno di quei
forse l'unico gioco della mia vita che
ho comprato a scatola chiusa senza aver
mai visto una mazza avevo letto solo la
trama dietro eroi big stop non ricordo
non se l'è mai pagato nessuno peccato
perché è un gran pezzo allora allora
allora di cosa parliamo qui allora
questo momento subito da parte perché il
primo che proviamo a reagan addio già
core agente un ora che è passato troppo
tempo non ci credo
lory cos'è sta così questo sgorbio sto
preparando crossing crossing ragazzi è
il nome della mia città non fate domande
per favore non avevo fantasie un bambino
biotech e insultate un bambino è normale
che chiama la città con il nome del
gioco non avevo fantasia basta basta
mettere dislike asti lido basta non mi
ricordo niente di quello che ciò in giro
niente non so neanche cosa ciò
nell'inventare vediamo in dio ciò dei
mobili lava lampo gluck di lava lampo
rosa pancia esotica va bene non vedono
andare da qualche parte comunque ragazza
incredibile ci sono passati secoli
ancora c'è il mio guarda quante erbacce
che schifo che schifo orribile perché
poi quando passa un sacco di tempo si
riempiva other barci la città va beh
anche in animo incrocio lo nuovo però
far cava che roba non mi ricordo niente
non sai che dove sto andando
sono tornato adesso dovrei essere
vecchio era un bambino l'ultima volta
coperto stato villaggio io sia qualcosa
che ho scritto un batterio che spera di
no tutta roba del 2020 comunque quindi
vuol dire che non è rimasto niente delle
robe vecchie
che sfiga peccato sarebbe stato figo
vedere un messaggio mio vabbè ai ragazzi
st e stato veramente incredibile
chissenefrega arrivare detti pokémon
versione perla perché comunque sia
ragazzi se ci pensate po che non è stata
un po l'infanzia di tutti ma questo
credo che sia stato il mio secondo
pokémon più giocato il primo era pokémon
rubino e pokemon smeraldo mettiamo allo
stesso posto perché li ho giocati tutti
di un sacco di pazzesco
una donna incredibile mi sembrava tutto
così moderno ed è tempo 75 o farci dall
aria wired ma dio trani dott
perché cerioli per lo 1 questa parola
perché c'è un golem giapponese porta pac
ma con chi stavo facendo scambi
no ragazzi ho capito cosa è successo ho
capito i pokemon forti me li hanno
scambiati sui pokémon platino perché
avevo preso anche pokemon platino prima
che non pokemon platino non so se sia
fini ma allora questi invece sono il
professor layton questi due sono
l'eredità degli aslan e la maschera dei
miracoli però questi sono quelli un po
più avanzati
io giocavo al primo quello che ho
giocato di più è stato il primo è il
paese dei misteri non ho idea di dove
sia finita la scatolina purtroppo però
ce l'ho ancora il giochino in schedina
dopo lo proviamo e smash questo direi
che possiamo metterlo quanto sapete
tutti come smash proprio lui il primo
professor layton ragazzi questo è stato
il mio primo professor layton che il
primo è uscito credo non meriti una
cagata lo sa è stato io a tutt'ora al
momento nella top 10 almeno dei giochi
più belli ai quali io abbia mai giocato
giuro su dio è un capolavoro pazzesco
qua abbiamo su continua dei dati salvati
tra cui perché lavori iniziato più volte
no co 12 ore di gioco qualora di gioco
20 ore perché vedete dal simbolo di
layton dorato l'avevo finito e quindi ho
tutti gli enigmi sbloccati tutti quanti
perché gli avevo praticamente finiti
me l'ero mangiato sto gioco era troppo
bello e allora non vi spoiler
malate riporta mentre vado avanti perché
vi fate di epilogo e quindi se io vado
teoricamente qui e vado su enigmi lui
merita tutti e 135 esatto tutti
completati e uno si può scegliere quello
che vuole come non vuole credo di aver
messo come preferiti quelli con la
faccina credo e non ne sono sicuro buon
vicinato dvd il porcile la ruota
panoramica risolvi lo non fate uno a
caso 0 87 vai questa ruota panoramica un
totale di dieci cabine da due persone la
ruota gira in modo che ogni minuto una
cabina passi davanti all'uscita se la
ruota entra in funzione alle 10 di
mattina si ferma a 30 minuti più tardi
qual è il numero massimo di persone che
possono aver fatto un giro sulla ruota
in questo arco di tempo dieci cabine da
due persone nessuno perché le 10 della
mattina che carai gara già aprire il mio
cassetto il cra del kriens soffrivo di
egocentrismo un po di tempo fa 90 piero
degli iscritti che stavo facendo quindi
va bè ipod touch tattico però questi non
sono videogiochi
se sono qua eccolo eccolo allora gameboy
advance sp tattico e la [ __ ] pioveva
veramente di bestia allora vedo che
dentro c'è già pokemon robinho perché ho
giocato anche negli anni in realtà
abbiamo ce n'è un altro qua dimenticato
abb è certa della si vabbè zelda era
scontato allora noto che ho un sacco di
nintendo giro non so per quale motivo
questo non lo posso neanche provare
avevo dette space per la wii era una
cosa incredibile che poi battlefield per
il computer signori e di cosa che
commenti vorreste fare scusatemi
tenetevi per voi
allora ragazzi ci siamo teoricamente
dovrei aver tutto preso l'ultima allora
questo epoche un cristallo
qualcuno di voi hanno visto solenne al
museo egizio di torino è esposta da
qualche parte lo mettiamo qua perché
proviamo anche questo come potete vedere
qua dietro c'è appunto
pokémon rubino che vi ho menzionato
prima e ci sono un sacco di giochi
abbiamo un altro paio di giochi per game
boy che sono tomb raider ragazzi gioco
con la grafica più brutta della storia
lo vedrete questo era un gioco di yu gi
oh
a mio parere il migliore esistente della
schedina era in giapponese
questo invece era un altro new york le
carte leggendari vabbè arriviamo quindi
al pokémon quello buono ma per farlo
dobbiamo cominciare con sol perché
quella è troppo moderna non può più ok
scherzavo dovrei averci non altro se non
erro eccolo vi chiederete perché noi due
non ve lo posso dire
ecco non ho male questo a carico tra due
almeno uno carico il mio originale era
questo lo riconosco perché c'è una
scheggia questo qua invece non è molto
più nuovo questa nuovissima in realtà è
un pezzo di antiquariato tenuto da dio a
versione rubino la batteria interna
discarica è possibile giocare
tuttavia non si verificheranno gli
eventi collegati al 78 ore di gioco 78
peggiore l'altro prima di vedere i
pokemon decenti almeno qua ti prego non
avere cagate non avere cagate cos'è sta
merda perché c'è unico che continua per
l'effetto di pokémon a 20 per cento io
ma dai impegnativi
abbiamo tutto loeb è al 100 che sono
finite a nel box forse no perché non è
una ragazza non ci voglio credere
i giorni impegniamo un sacco geico e
dicasteri co batista ma sono i nomi dei
break
perché dava i nomi dei i nomi dei
wrestler li davo ai box ma che problemi
avevo comunque sono tutti kagari possono
anche quando ragazzi vi giuro avevo
visto che non al centro semplicemente
melis cambiamo su ogni volta che usciva
un nuovo pokémon mi scambiavo i pokémon
del pokemon prima melis cambiamo in
quello nuovo perché diceva degli alleati
di scambio lino è un furbo il problema
che dovete cui il pokemon più aggiornato
e che ne so quindi non me li posso far
vedere c'è la a mio cugino i miei
pokémon non me li posso non vi posso
prevedere ne andiamo con pokémon
cristallo torniamo sempre più indietro
nel tempo fino ad arrivare al a tetris
se non prendere anche tutto lo schermo
2001 alcuni voi ma ancora nati cioè ma
dai nuovo gioco ma no come no dove sono
i miei danno ma giusto erano perché i
dati si salvarono sulla schedina si
salvano sul game boy ma perché mi sa che
allora ci ha ragione e problema che
allora dopo sull'altro che in poi solo
che scarico ma va avanti
[Musica]